اهلا مشاهدينا ننتقل مباشره الى الزميل
عبد الرحمن الاعصامي زميلنا عبد الرحمن
العصيمي متواجد حاليا في المركز الموحد
لمهمه حدث الاطلاق يمكن بدات تظهر بعض
الصور للمركبه او فتح باب المركبه حدثنا
المشهد من عندك يا عبد الرحمن كيف
نعم ساره نحن في هذا المركز الذي تقريبا
ساره يعني مهمته الرسميه شبه انتهت بمجرد
التحام المركبه بمحطه الفضاء ايضا نلاحظ
خلال الساعات الماضيه كانت الصوره دائما
على المركز الموجود في الولايات المتحده
لكن الان حتى صوره المركز في الولايات
المتحده تقريبا اختفت وتم التركيز الصوره
على
محطه او المركبه مركبه دراغون التي التحمت
قبل تقريبا اقل من ساعتين
بمحطه الفضاء طبعا متوقع ساره
فتح باب الكبسوله تحضيرا لنزول ريانه وعلي
تقريبا الساعه السادسه وربع
تقريبا بعد عشر دقائق احنا ربما الى 20
دقيقه عبد الرحمن احنا شايفين الان يمكن
باب مفتوح وبداوا يقوموا من الكراسي
فيبدو انه في تحركات
متوقع انه بدا
صحيح
صحيح ساره ومتوقع ايضا انه يكون هناك في
احتفاليه مصغره للترحيب بريانه وعلي من
قبل سبعه رواد
موجودين سابقا في محطه الفضاء الدوليه
احتفاليه مصغره
صحيح ساره ومتوقع ايضا تلقي ريان ويلقي
علي كلمتين
بسيطتين بهذه المناسبه ثم يبداان مهمتهما
المتعلقه بالبحوث واستكشاف
الفضاء ساره يعني ردود فعل الشارع السعودي
حقيقه ردود عظيمه وكبيره وواسعه خلال
يومين الماضيين وايضا تم اقامه ثلاث معارض
موجوده في مركز اثراء في الظهران وايضا في
العاصمه الرياض وجده هذه المعارض مهمتها
ابراز هذه
الرحله بشكل كبير للسعوديين وتركيز ايضا
على قيمه واهميه هذه الرحله وانعكاساتها
على قطاع الفضاء في السعوديه ساره يعني
هذه الرحله متوقعه منها عبد الرحمن انا بس
حاضطر اني اوقفك دقيقه لانه الان بداوا
يدخلوا او بداوا يطلعوا من المركبه
الدراغون من الكبسوله اللي هم فيها وعشان
يدخلوا الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه تحذيرا
الان بيصير اللي هو تحضير نزول الرواد
طبعا هي الموضوع نحن شفنا احد دخل الان
لكن ليس يبدو انه ريان لا زالت في
الكبسوله ما احنا متاكدين من هويات
الشخصيات اللي او الشخصيه اللي خرجت حتى
الان ممكن طبعا هم معاهم في هذه علامتنا
هذه المركبه اللي هي دراغون معاهم مركبه
دراغون معهم اثنين كمان رواد فضاء
امريكيين فهما يعني ممكن يكون احدهم برضا
بس برضه بس انه يعني الان بدانا نشوف
التحركات وبدات فعلا الباب انفتح وبنشوف
التفاصيل طبعا كما ذكر زميلي يعني عبد
الرحمن الع صيمي لمن حيخرجوا من
الكبسوله احنا
الان شايفين على الشاشه سلطان النيادي
اللي هو الرائد الفضاء الاماراتي وهو احد
الاشخاص الموجودين في وكاله الفضاء
الدوليه وكان كتب او محطه محطه الفضاء
الدوليه وكانكتب عن التغريدات بعض من
التغريدات عن حماسه لاستقبال رواد الفضاء
السعوديين وانه العالم السعودي والاماراتي
سيجتمعوا في الفضاء هو واحد من سبعه رواد
فضاء موجودين في محطه الفضاء الدوليه صار
لهم فتره بيقوموا ببعض الابحاث هناك وهذه
طبعا حيكون اول مره يجتمع هذا العدد في
الفضاء واصلا بوصول ريانه وبوصول علي
القرني ايضا وريان برناوي سيكون عدد
السعوديين ايضا اللي وصلوا الى الفضاء
ثلاثه و بهذا الشيء حتكون السعوديه هي
الاولى عربيا اللي ثلاثه رواد فضاء طبعا
مشاهدينا احنا اتكلمنا كنا في البدايه عن
انه هذه الرحله سيقوم من خلال رواد الفضاء
السعوديين بعدد من التجارب العلميه كمان
خلينا بس نذكر مشاهدينا انه قبل ساعات
التحمت المركبه مع محطه الفضاء
الدوليه الان نحن في مرحله فتح باب
الكبسوله علشان ينزلوا منها رواد وبدانا
بالفعل بنشوف هذه الحركه ومن ثم سيكون في
احتفاليه استقبال للرواد في محطه الفضاء
الدوليه من قبل الرواد اللي موجودين في
المحطه خليني ارجعلك عبد الرحمن انت كنت
تتكلم عن ردود الافعال وبالفعل ردود
الافعال يعني كانت كبيره جدا امس كل الناس
جالسه بتتفرج وبتشوف طبعا هذه المشاهد
ومشاهد الرحله طبعا احنا الان المشاهد
اللي بن المشاهدين بس خلينا نوضح انها هي
من محطه الفضاء الدوليه هذول رواد الفضاء
اللي موجودين حاليا في المحطه
وسيستعدوا او يستعدوا حاليا
لاستقبال رواد الفضاء اللي جايين من مركبه
دراغون اللي منهم اثنين سعوديين طبعا
ريانه برناوي وعلي القرني وعلي معهم ايضا
اثنين رواد فضاء امريكيين طيب خليني
ارجعلك عبد الرحمن انت طبعا في قلب المكان
او منطقه التحكم في السعوديه اذا تحكي لي
من عندك انت ايش صاير الان
نعم ساره فعلا نحن ايضا نشاهد هذه اللقطات
دراغون التي التحمت قبل ساعتين بمحطه
الفضاء الدوليه ايضا نشاهد الان بعض من
رواد الفضاء الذين يستعدون لاستقبال ريانه
وعلي برفقه ايضا كما قلت رائدي الفضاء
الامريكيين
المتقاعدين طبعا من وكاله ناسا ولذيني
يحملان خبره طويله في هذا المجال لمساعده
ريانه وعلي طبعا ساره ريان وعلي لديهم
مهام محدده خلال هذه الرحله الهيئه
السعوديه للفضاء كشفت ان لديهما 11 بحثا
سيجريانه على محطه الفضاء الدوليه حول
الجاذبيه الصغرى وانعدام الوزن في الفضاء
ايضا هناك ثلاث تجارب بحثيه وتعليميه
توعويه حول علوم الخلايا وايضا عمل
الامطار الصناعيه الى جانب طبعا الجاذبيه
الصغرى السعوديون مدعوون ساره لمتابعه هذه
الرحله اولا باول عبر المعارض الثلاثه
الموجوده في الظهران والرياض وجده وايضا
عبر موقع هيئه الفضاء السعوديه
لمتابعه كل المحطات وكل الناس
كل المحطات وكل الناس جالسين ينقلوا وطبعا
ريانه وعلي كمان تحدثوا انهم سيقوموا
بتوثيق الرحله على حساباتهم على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي طبعا بالاضافه الى هيئه
الفضاء وبالفعل كما ذكرت اصلا في كثير
الان هاشتاقات الناس بتسجل وبتوثق بيه
فيديوهات لحظات الوصول هذه وفي حاله ترقب
انه نشوفهم وهم خارجين
وبيدخلوا طبعا خلينا نقول محطه الفضاء
الدوليه
المثير للانتباه ساره ايضا عوائد هذه
الرحله على السعوديه يعني موضوع التركيز
على الابتكار موضوع التركيز على مستقبل
الفضاء وتقنيه الاتصالات التركيز ايضا على
تحفيز الجيل الجديد في السعوديه لا ننسى
ساره انه 70% من المجتمع السعودي هم من
الشباب وهذه الرحله ستكون مصدر الهام
للكثير من الشباب السعوديين للدخول مثل في
مثل هذه التخصصات التي تشكل جزء كبير من
المستقبل البشريه عبد الرحمن يعني خلينا
شويه انا وانت يعني سعوديين ونحاز على
الهواء مباشره ونكون صريحين يعني امس
صراحه كل احد كان جالس بيتكلم حتى انه
بالحركه هذه بطلوع ريانه برناوي للفضاء
انه الواحد صار يقدر يقول للبنات انه ما
عاد في اي حدود لطموحكم ممكن الان حتى
تكونوا رائده فضاء وكان هذا صراحه واحده
من كثير الاشياء اللي تشاركوا الناس في
الحديث عنها
صحيح المراه السعوديه ساره يعني خطط خطوات
كبيره خلال فتره قصيره طبعا بفضل رؤيه
2030 ريانه هي اول رائده فضاء مسلمه عربيه
تكون موجوده في محطه الفضاء الدوليه بكل
تاكيد ستكون هذه القصه مصدر الهام لسنوات
طويله ساره يمكن جيلي وجيلك كنا متاثرين
كثير في رحله الامير سلطان بن سلمان الى
الفضاء عام 1985 طبعا انا وانت ولدنا
بعدها عشان ما نكبر انفسنا
قلقتني يا عبد الرحمن لما بدات تقول جيلنا
ههه
لا اتكلم انه مدار بمدارس في السعوديه
درسنا في المناهج درسنا ايضا في المدارس
كان دائما سلطان بن سلمان الامير مصدر
الهام لتغيير من السعوديين خلال اجيال
وايضا ريان او علي سيكونان مصدر الهام
لاجيال القادمه ففعلا الامر ليس بالسهل
وسيكون تاثيره بشكل كبير على ملايين
السعوديين خلال السنوات
او سهل يعني كميه التدريبات اللي خضعوا
لها طوال الفتره الماضيه كيفيه التعايش
داخل محطه فضاء دوليه التدريب على موضوع
محاكاه الانطلاق بعدين كل التجهيزات اللي
عندهم علشان عدد الابحاث اللي انت حتى
ذكرتها اللي حيقوموا فيها في محطه الفضاء
الدوليه وانا كمان حابه اذكر ايضا
المثير للانتباه ايضا
المدير الانتباه ساره انه ايضا عدد
السعوديين الموجودين في الولايات المتحده
والذين حضروا اطلاق
الدراغون هناك وايضا عدد كبير يعني يمكن
ربما يتجاوز المئات وفي ناس يا ساره يعني
غادروا من السعوديه الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه خصيصا لهذه المناسبه على حسابهم
الشخصي فهذا يدل ايضا على اهميه هذه
الرحله وانها ستشكل فارق كبير في مشهد
يعني يعني لحظه تاريخيه ورحله تاريخيه
والكل يعني محتفي فيها انا كمان كنت بقول
لك عبد الرحمن انه انا حابه اذكر انه
السلطه انه يعني ريانه وعلي طبعا يعني
شخصيات ما تم اختيارهم بس كذا لا هم يعني
شخصيات بارزه وطبعا عندهم يعني خلينا نقول
شهادات علميه عاليه يعني ريانه برنامج
اللي هي اول فتاه سعوديه عربيه مسلمه تطلع
لي الفضاء هي باحثه في مجال الخلايا
الجذعيه وكمان درست علم الهندسه الوراثه
صحيحه عبد الرحمن خلينا الان بنشوف ظهروا
رواد الفضاء بداوا يخرجوا من مركبه
الادراجن شاهدنا احد الرواد الامريكيين
الرائده خرجت من
دخلت المحطه الفضاء الدوليه الان يبدو هذا
هو الرائد الامريكي ايضا يخرج
خلينا نشوف طيب وهذا علي علي القرني يدخل
الان الى محطه الفضاء
الدوليه طبعا هذه اللحظات التاريخيه
وبيسلموا على بعض وبيحتفوا
بوصولهم نحن كمان في انتظار دخول ريانه
ايضا
الان خلينا نقول انه طبعا علي القرني هو
يعني دارس لعلوم الطيران في كليه الملك
فيصل الجويه وبيعمل مقاتل برتبه نقيب طيار
على طائرات اف 15
هو كمان يعني احد الشخصيات ايضا البارزه
بيسلم عليهم وهو مقلوب طبعا مع انعدام
الجاذبيه يلا نزلوه دخلت ريانه برناوي
الان الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه اذا
مشاهدينا بنشاهد الان ريانه
البرناوي اول يعني امراه عربيه سعوديه
مسلمه بتصل الى الفضاء ومحطه الفضاء
الدوليه طبعا احنا الان بنشاهد امامنا هذه
لحظات تاريخيه لحظات طبعا يعني
كلنا يعني نشعر في خلالها طبعا بالسعاده
وبالفخر وسعيدين جدا بوصولهم بالسلامه
وبهذا الانجاز التاريخي عبد الرحمن كيف
الاوضاع عندك في المركز
لحظه تاريخيه بكل المقاييس ساره لحظه يعني
انا فخور باني جزء منها لحظه
ستخلد في ذاكره السعوديين لسنوات طويله
لحظه ايضا
ستقوم بنقل كبيره لقطاع الفضاء في
السعوديه لحظه يساره اعتقد ان السعوديين
كلهم كانوا بانتظارها منذ اطلاق المركبه
قبل اكثر من سته عشر ساعه وايضا عندما
كانوا اولا باول يراقبون الترتيبات لهذه
الرحله وايضا عندما استقبل ولي عهد
السعودي
اطاقم هذه الرحله رفقه وزير
الاتصالات
قبل تقريبا في شهر رمضان الماضي هذه
الرحله
ربما ايضا تشكل حافز كبير للكثير من
السعوديين
الراغبين في الانضمام لمثل هذه التجارب
العلميه
يعني هناك عوائد ساره متوقعه على السعوديه
من ناحيه تفعيل الابتكارات العلميه في
البرنامج على مستوى علوم الفضاء ايضا هناك
تركيز على تنميه المهارات فيما يتعلق
بالاهتمام بخريجي مجالات الهندسه الفضائيه
وعلوم التقنيه ايضا هناك
تعزيز لمكانه السعوديه نحو السباق العالمي
للفضاء وان هذا البرنامج سيمهد الطريق
لطموح السعوديه في مجال استكشاف الفضاء
ايضا هذه الرحله ستشكل يعني خارج الطريق
للسعوديه لاجراء ابحاثها الخاصه بشكل
مستقل فيما يتعلق بابحاث وعلوم الفضاء
السعوديه لديها تجارب سابقه عبر الامير
سلطان بن سلمان والان تؤكد ايضا بانها
تتجه قدما تجاه الفضاء وتعزيز مكانتها وفق
طبعا رؤيه
2030 علي وريانه
اكثر من 30 مليون سعودي يعلقان امالهم
عليهما صحيح عبد الرحمن ويعني لو شفنا على
تويتر كمان غير انه كان فيها هاشتاق
السعوديه نحو الفضاء في كمان هاشتاق اللي
هو ترند وفي كل الناس كانوا بيحطوه اللي
هو طموحنا عنان السماء واللي هو طبعا من
كلمات سمو ولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان
برضو اصبح واحد من الهاشتاقات الى الناس
جالسه بتستخدمها وخليني كمان بس اضيف على
كلامك عبد الرحمن عن
الابحاثاره ترند طبعا اكيد ريانا برناوي
وعلي القرني طبعا على اساميهم ترند هذا
بالتاكيد يعني بس كمان كنت حابب اضيف على
موضوع الابحاث اللي انت بتقول عنها انه
هذه الابحاث مو بس مهمه لمجال الفضاء هي
ايضا ستستخدم في اشياء برضه لها علاقه
بالصحه على الارض وعلاجات على الارض طيب
عبد الرحمن احنا الان
ابحاث بشريه في علوم الخلايا صحيح طيب عبد
الرحمن ايضا الصناعيه في الجاذبيه الصغرى
الاستمطار صحيح عبد الرحمن نحن الان خلينا
نروح فاصل ونرجع حتى بس انت طبعا خليك
معانا احنا حنروح فاصل ونرجع وان شاء الله
يكونوا هم شكلهم دخلوا جوا في المحطه يعني
يا ريت تدخلوا بعمرك عشان نكمل نشوف بس ان
شاء الله لما نرجع نشوف المزيد من المشاهد